merci beaucoup
merci Emmanuel
monsieur le Président
Madame présidente d'interlène
Premier ministre de coussin peut-être
Premier ministre Fiat premier les chers
dirigeants des institutions avec mes
ministres schmigal cher Olena et tous
les présents ministres présents et les
ambassadeurs je suis heureux que nous
sommes réunis au sein de cette nouvelle
conférence
et nous sommes réunis dans le désir de
vaincre l'intérieur énergétique je me
rappelle lorsque Emmanuel Macron m'a
téléphoné
en posant d'organiser ce format et
il a il y a déjà eu des premières
frappes il est la terreur des drones
iraniens étaient déjà présentes
en essayant de provoquer la
catastrophe humanitaire dans tous les
pays
la Russie avait besoin de terroriser
l'Ukraine et tout le monde démocratique
et en réponse nous avons
nous nous font tout pour contrer le
blackout et la terreur énergétique
qu'avons-nous aujourd'hui l'Ukraine
c'est dressé contre des dizaines des
centaines de frappes russes d'antécité
variable dans notre secteur de l'énergie
mais maintenant la plupart de nos
centrales électriques sont endommagées
et détruits par les bombardements toutes
les centrales hydrauliques les centrales
thermiques
imaginez vous ce qui est cela
signifierait dans vos pays l'une des
frapperus a provoqué l'arrêt de toutes
les unités nucléaires de nos centrales
mais tout a marché
et heureusement
seul et la restauration rapide
superficielle des installations
énergétiques détruites par les fratrus
nécessite au moins un milliard et demi
d'euros chaque fois après chaque frappe
russe nous essayons de restaurer la
capacité technique de produire et
fournir les détricité pourtant chaque
jour nos ingénieurs en énergie doivent
déconnecter des millions du craignant de
l'approvisionnement en raison d'une
grave pénurie d'électricité dans le sang
du système électrique à l'heure actuelle
environ 12 millions de personnes dans
presque toutes les régions
qui sont déconnectés de
l'approvisionnement malheureusement il
s'agit d'une situation type et chaque
jour nous nous attendons à de nouvelles
frappes russes c'est que peut
considérablement augmenter le nombre de
pannes c'est pour ça que les générateurs
et les alimentations sans interruption
sont devenues aussi nécessaires en
Ukraine que les véhicules blindés et les
gilets par balles c'est le seul moyen de
protéger les champs ordinaires et le
système social compte dans les
conditions du Paris russe sur le
blackout en fait un système
le service de production d'énergie de
centralisée et en cours de construction
en France et en Ukraine il est construit
très rapidement dans toutes les régions
mais il y a des milliers d'entreprises
ukrainiennes de petites et moyennes
entreprises d'équipements sociaux
continuent de fonctionner grâce à des
générateurs ainsi les hôpitaux
fonctionnent sur des générateurs grâce
au générateur des centaines des milliers
d'emplois ont été déjà sauvés la
connexion Internet il est une
télécommunication dans tous les pays
plus de 5000 points d'invincibilité ont
été ouvert c'est des lieux où les gens
peuvent se réchauffer chargés leurs
appareils et je suis reconnaissant à
partenaire qui aident déjà à l'Ukraine
dans l'équipement avec l'équipement et
approprié par maintenir ce niveau de
stabilité énergétique dans notre état et
pour notre société dans moi l'attache
clé est de préserver le principal
système énergétique de l'Ukraine de
garantir son fonctionnement stablement
malgré toutes les tentatives russes de
faire de l'Ukraine l'endroit le plus
sombre de l'Europe c'est pour ça ce
format est nécessaire ici et maintenant
nous devons nous mettre d'accord sur des
choses spécifiques qui n'aideront pas
seulement l'Ukraine à survivre à l'hiver
mais qui pourront aussi plus vite que
possible et aider toutes les forces
démocratiques
faire que pour en faire en sorte que les
forces un petit démocratique et
anti-européenne en premier lieu la
Russie
[Musique]
prévenir les catastrophes et à protéger
les citoyens
nous avons besoin de plusieurs
catégories d'équipements les
transformateurs équipements pour la des
réseaux à haute tension turbine à gaz et
motocropulseur à piston à gaz les
présentants
Ukrainiens présents à la conférence
peuvent vous informer de toutes les
spécifications
techniques de cette demande un autre un
autre système énergétique a besoin ou
moins jusqu'à la fin de la saison de
chauffage en
Ukraine d'une aide d'urgence du système
pour le système énergétique du système
de la part du système énergétique
européen c'est à dire l'importation de
l'électricité des pays de le en Ukraine
pour cela pour que ça soit possible de
son besoin d'une solution de l'euro net
des gestionnaires des réseaux de
transport d'électricité pour augmenter
la capacité à emporter encore une fois
tous les détails techniques et sont
présentés par nos représentants
cela coûtera à peu près 800 millions
d'euros
c'est très important mais c'est plus
important
mais le prix est moindre que le coût de
ce blackout et c'est pour ça que
j'espère que ces décisions seront prises
dans le cadre de cette conférence
les missions de l'UE
qu'il faut envoyer partout dans les
toutes les centrales en
Ukraine nous demandons d'envoyer
l'émission comme ça partout en
Ukraine parce que il y a la stabilité de
toutes nos régions qui est dépendent de
ça ces missions de l'UE seront un
facteur
sécurité
garantiront la sécurité et le contrôle
de la pointe de l'Europe à cause de la
destruction des centrales électriques
par les terroristes sont obligés
d'utiliser Tunis des gaz cet hiver que
prévu en conséquence nous avons besoin
d'acheter environ 2 milliards de mètres
cubes de gaz c'est aussi un élément
nécessaire de notre stabilité qui a
besoin de votre leaders un autre
cinquième point
un autre résultat pratique de cette
conférence pourrait devenir un accord
sur le financement d'un projet
dont un manuel a commencé déjà parlé de
l'achat de l'aide pour l'Ukraine cela
peut ne pas sembler très important mais
50 millions de saisons
économiser permettent d'économiser
environ un gigawatt d'électricité étant
de nos que le déficit moyen de notre
réseau électrique et d'environ de deux
gigawatts et demi
et nous avons besoin aussi d'un
mécanisme spécial permanent de
coordination des efforts le mécanisme de
Paris ce qui permettra de donner des
réponses rapides et efficaces à tous les
défis en story par la terreur
énergétique russe jusqu'à présent
malheureusement nous n'avons disposons
pas encore d'un système de défense
anti-harien aussi moderne
pour abattre
100% de missiles des drones russes mais
non pourrons créer un système de prise
de vision qui peut complètement privé la
Russie de ça de son empathe de l'impact
de cette technique terroriste lorsque la
stabilité énergétique de l'Ukraine sera
garantie pendant toute cette période
hivernale
cela pour empêcher les vagues de
migration massives dans votre pays et
aucune frappe aucune panne d'électricité
aucune
frappe armée ne pourra aider la Russie à
réaliser ça la Russie devra
réfléchir à sa manière d'arrêter cette
agression et je crois que ce sera entre
non mais c'est entre nos mains entre vos
mains je vous remercie encore monsieur
le Président d'avoir organisé cette
conférence j'espère vraiment des
une décision concrètes merci gloire à
l'Ukraine
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup cher volo Dimir